Hello everyone, very good
Joe's you [
appreciation]
A new news, please read the syllabus, will there be a
board exam or not,
this will happen while doing something, Misbah asks sir, '
Who is my partner, sir,
I am feeling like this'
Ritika is
saying that both the
fights are going to happen, do they
want it or not, should it not happen at all,
we are talking about the 24 year exam, we are going to start
our preparation from now onwards
and as you guys
can also tell,
on.  Right date ok,
now I have seen that it is already December, it is
August and September, I don't know what the syllabus is, I do
n't know where it comes from, the
syllabus
is in two days and I am having such doubts,
sir, this is the solution.  Do
pressure time to
solve this problem. I
think now CBSE has taken a very good initiative
and how will we know what has been
deleted and what has not. Some children were saying
that the entire chapter has been deleted
or else.  Some people are saying that a lot of
things have been added, so there is a lot of confusion that the
children are facing. Today we are going to clear it. If there
is light in both, then basically
it opens from this place. Come on,
write Hi quickly, we will take the name.
Ashok Gaming yes welcome,
I too thought the same thing, friend, my previous one has
done it, give me a band - say
no, no, it will not happen, I would not
like that you board exam is
going to be as it is,
girls and inside, they are left but they can be right.
Always write,
so on date, note, let's get started from you,
bill is needed, what else brother, I have to say with folded hands,
after today, don't keep this confusion in your heart about
where to look for the syllabus, where to look for the book,
exactly madam, it is absolutely Google, see, it has
opened in front of you.  I
entered CBSE Syllabus
202324 in Google. Did you understand? Intere from there. I
entered the
first result which is yours for the whole year.
If you are interested in the syllabus then
this is the biggest tip that you are
telling to some children who are infatuated.  Where do you want to go, then this
CBSE will cost
you ₹ 50 even after opening Google, but we have to
go to CBSE academic.in only and the
most important point which Akash Sir had
also said earlier is that if the children do
not even know the syllabus, then it is important to know the syllabus.  You should always have a copy
and when it comes to your board examination,
if you want to study that part of the syllabus, then I will say, read it, you should
study it, this is the language, once
everything will start later, so
this is what is right now, the rest is the thing.  Meaning, whatever
you feel right now is not very important,
but when will you do it later, once the syllabus
starts, it means teachers will be busy studying,
you will not have time at all,
so whatever you are getting right now,
you will just do it.  Whatever you want to study, read all the extras.
I am saying that it
means that you have got success in any subject,
this is going to happen in Physics,
this is going to happen in Chemistry, then only you will know.
Well, I am expecting all this.
Now actually as we are seeing that
if there is a language then you
can go to the language, I have subjects and mother subjects, I
actually have my own subject so
let us see. Okay, so here our three
main subjects which are common to all.
Look, Maths and Science are already there, your Social
Science will also be found here. Okay, so there is no
need to further provoke you on the story too. You
don't have to ask Sir.
Do you understand English? Obviously it is English.
If yours is Hindi, but  By the way,
you get the syllabus of Hindi also, it is also
available in Hindi, now authentically, they are
focusing on this group, so sir, now we will
explain to you in the major of Maths, okay then
we will come to science right and then we will
also see what is there in the books.  -What has changed,
otherwise I have also gone to the publication,
remove it, it is not going well, I am not
very good at it, you will focus on
science
once again, we would have gone there, only
here we got Maths, okay.  And
here you can get science also, okay, so
how is it like this sir, its class is also there, so they bill
do de science, it
is absolutely okay sir, come on right, don't say
that you will get both in this, some
children were saying not even nine's.  Will you tell me,
this is the pay of nine, so I can
do school once,
you can get Dr from D page, okay, so now here you have got it, okay, we have the
same tax units, big
units,
okay, so
here  You guys are watching Unit One,
Unit One is for what, children, Unit One is for
Chemistry, okay, so here is
our syllabus, from here till here the
full name of the chapter unit is given,
here along with it you have also mentioned the chapter.
So what do you people have to do with it,
as the other teachers have said that whatever
complete PF is visible,
it has to be printed out with nine pages and then
as you gradually progress, your
Units will be finished and you
can tick them. Okay, so here's the
syllabus of ninth class. We
don't have chemistry in ninth class. Okay,
so now here's the situation in
our bio that is the chapter on diversity.  Is it
deleted? It is not necessary because
sometimes schools can take theirs on tomorrow, come on the ninth day, it
is okay CBSE,
if your school people are teaching you diversity,
then we too are not going to study,
okay, I am going to study because right
now  Our YouTube session is going to start immediately, let
it remain a surprise and in the end, all
four of us teachers will tell you, okay, I have to
say, even if something has been deleted in the ninth, I will
comment, read everything,
if you like, take the future.  Like if I want to
become a doctor or engineer or want to take this
then all these topics are repeated from 9th and 10th,
9th has a direct link
with 11th and 10th with 12th so if you are
planning to become Doctor Engineer Told
Exactly.  There is a right infact youtube
chapter, isn't it, this is the
beginning of the chapter of 129, the rate of 11th is
very important, this is your route,
thank you, so the same is your basic unit, now
you people also have time, many
children also get confused in infact.  Is it necessary to do or
not to do, then if
you read it in a little detail now, you will get it,
yes, according to CBSE people, tell me, are there
any five bio's only cells and tissue,
friend, it is good, it is less, yes, and
in an environment.  You must have read that the bus
is from here to here, so there is motion in it, everything
is there, nothing is deleted in this, force of
force and loss of motion, only one
part in this is delivery date, this is conservation of linear
momentum, rest is the same as
gravity flotation.  Energy is all the
same and as far as I have heard, the
teachers in your school like this chapter called
Gravity Floatation the most, so all the
difficult questions that come come from this,
isn't it fantastic?
Last topic here.  If you will be
interested, it is quite new and different, so
here I can see a small change
which they have given the rate of food pulses, so
usually what we used to do used to go
in the chapter of crop production and management, so
now the rate is in this chapter.
I am also looking at it, it is looking a little sorted,
it is more than before and
he has given pulses in fruit production.
Okay, so this is also a chapter of my bio, my
son's Plant and Animal Breeding, Selection,
Quality Improvement, Management,
Fertilizers.  Manual, all these things have
come the same, if it is okay in crop production management and
agriculture management, then
everything will remain the same, animal breeding, plant
breeding, animal husbandry, practicals in the major of that, it
depends on the school, again it
is okay and for that also we have
A surprise for you about this practical
area,
we will tell you about it in the last section. Okay, now the
10th syllabus is from
five to first chemistry. The
first one, children, is always chemistry. There is
ninth and tenth, so come
here.  The confusion that was there is now the last one,
one of our chapters was cut,
so the children thought that they had read some of it,
some people, now that confusion has been
completely removed by NCERT,
what do you have now, these four chapters are short and short.  It
is Chemical Reaction Acid Base and
Salt Metal and Nonmetals and Carbon
Compounds which was the fifth chapter which we do
not have to read, so it is a very good thing
that one chapter has already been completed.
Yes, it is not at all, you will not find it
in the book, it is fine.  So, this was the only thing I had and some
rest, whatever we had read on the last air is the
same. Okay, so
what was in my bio, I am the one with the same
life process, whose festival
is the biggest chapter of science and
all the things are the same.  Living being,
he has also given here the rest, the
basic concept of nutrition, respiration,
transportation, expression, all the
living beings, which is the living organism,
right from D, TV, microorganism, you, what am I, we will tell you about
all of them
there, here we will tell you this in 12th.  Well,
living being was the concept of what is it, what is it, what is
called living, what is called
non-living, what are the factors,
so from here the questions of Meet also come,
tell me, when I was in this, I
gave a processor, meaning I took bio in 11th.  It
was not there, but one has to study everything.
That sir always used to come in Physics, Chemistry, Maths, Bio and Bio
and the first question was what is
this life, so everything is
around, this is right, so in the same way,
control and coordination has its own
chapter, rate has been kept again.  There
is a chapter on Reproduction, that too
is from Hereditary and Evolution. No, I
will tell you an interesting thing that there is Hereditary
and Evolution and what have these people done in PF.
Okay, so
what have the CBSE people done here?
Actually it is written that there is editing here,
similarly you will see the rate in the previous one also,
if you look at last year's syllabus
then it is of 23rd grade, we cannot do that,
but yes, whatever it is, they have
kept it, I don't know further.  Jaake maybe mind change ho jaaye
note this air do ok so topic
excluded r like
evolution actually ye jo syllabus ka dr tha re tu kyon
hua tha aa basically aapke jo scenario
super scenario batch thi use time mein covid chala
lockdown chala right aur usme mein  Our
exams were not even held and what happened in between was that because they are not able to
complete this syllabus, CBSE has taken this as
you know and
initiated the raising of this syllabus
and it has given good results to these juniors.
Mameed means children.  Has got so much
benefit that you can see how much the
syllabus has been reduced. Anyway, I kept it as it was. I was
thinking that maybe I am going to be among the 20-24,
but it happened like this. It was
really lucky. Right from the beginning, I
started asking.  It is given that let's
finish the conversation which has started at its
rate so now after this can you talk in English so like I want
you just say some
student
or some people from some Northern India
back then they like Hindi and some
Student from South D India, he
likes English so he bill try you mix
and match ok so date which of you can understand ok
no ok natural film is the
coolest thing about physics do you know I
will disclose I don't let's go
for the last one  So A's name is Surprise Lake A
and it will mostly have all physics content,
I am not looking at it, Palak,
Mishra, these people will do it, but
like 80% of the content, this physics is very cool, so
what is natural here, everything is light in it.
Our lenses, mirrors, file, optical
devices, all that, nothing has been cut out of it,
they have everything,
after that, the effects of current, everything which is electric
current, there is nothing deleted in it
and the magnetic effect of current is this
topic.  When I taught it 2 years ago, it was
very difficult because it
required such topics as children and bread,
I was not able to understand it at all,
like Electric Motor, Electromagnetic
Induction, Alta Generator, DC, both, so the one which is
from the most difficult topic.  If you remove all then it has
become very easy now Sir Physics
and in this one more chapter of Physics is
visible. There will
not be too many equations etc.
Equations will come in 12th now,
what is the normal difference in it and the
light that has come in our house.  That story has come from somewhere else, so it is
not a DC, there is only
one, and here there was another chapter, Source
of Energy, the entire chapter has been removed.
Yes, that Chapter of Sources
was actually in Natural Resources only, a Chapter
of Sources.  And he used to give a
rate after doing R Environment, so R Environment
is still a child and it gives you full five marks,
child, it is okay, these are the marks
which you should keep in your pocket in advance, there is
no tension in this.  Rate
to direct questions, you
get here in CBSE from 'Environmental',
full five mark rates of this is a very important
and this is on this is you on off
brain kid of a situation over every
is fine aa apart from this and one more  It also happens that
management of resources,
natural resources, it does not come in the exam,
other life points of times come, yes it
goes to them in school, n project
based learning, so what does the teacher do, he will
not come to take internal marks, when CBSE said  It is given that if
these
chapters come then they will come from here and although
just now we had analyzed the paper, it was very easy because
yes, it
means all the children solved such a paper, it was very
comparatively fine, okay, so
this is our situation, it
is fine now.  We will talk about
practicals, so today we have
two announcements to give you and as you are
asking, the biggest problem
is what to do with reference book, friend, you have
done NCERT well, that means
I don't think it is not necessary.
Inside, we will keep doing
Fox Only on Meet for questions, 80% of what happens in Red Meet
comes from NCERT only, so
whatever it is, all my future doctors,
understand this from today itself, if you  Wanted to
prepare, this is the right
base, we make base from 9th to 10th,
if you study well from 10th to 9th
PCS, then many things remain clear to you,
I and that from 11th to 12th, when we move forward then we can
relate.  It is found that
these are the earthquakes of the chapter. Literally,
this is what happens and nothing else, like there is a
chapter of reproduction, like there is a
chapter of crop production, like there is a chapter of crop production, like there is a
chapter of the city, if you read it first then this
is again 910.  And the same thing
comes in the exam also, it also comes in the competitive exam,
so those
who have started studying properly from now on, must have read this note very well,
then it will help them to understand further, that is, to
understand the concept,
like if we have to build a building.  So
we say that whatever it is, it
should be very strong, so sleep is nothing but the
foundation rate. If the foundation is not strong, then no matter
how much multi storage you make on top of it
or make a small hut, it is going to
fall.  So
with this, these are the reference books and I have given the
text book which is given by our NCERT,
this is enough on the tenth great talking about
today, well today we will get it
done, okay, you become with us
and we will get it done, then that's it.  It will be okay, let's come, I have come here,
now we have
time for NCERT also, son, yes, you will have to
study then, no, let me
tell NCERT
from where the children will get it, or first let me
tell you about the maths class too, Sir.  Okay,
so they are requesting again,
this link is
ncert.nic.in,
after that I used to return the same books,
I think I had a better method after this, I
also started falling in love, oh there she is.  Have you
read this much? Yes, if you come here,
Jain,
you will do science again. You will get it in three languages, so let me
open a sample of mine and show you
Chapter One Chemistry
1 minute 1 minute Yes, you are here only.  Ours is the
first chapter and what you have to see is whether it
is latest or not, so here you
will see below in PF, it is
Rationalize 2023 24. So he told
that this one of ours is updated, rest if there is
some content inside.  So if you
watch the last air, this time you will see that it is
no different from the last air.
In this, I would like to tell you one more thing that if
you have already bought the books because
many schools had started and you know the
children are few.  Elastic is also a relief, so it's
like the ninth ends even before the ninth. So even
if they have bought it, it is
not a big deal like
your scenery people used to do, you just have to do the same, keep
marking and keep reading
Periodic Classification.  It used to be
this, see now that fifth chapter has been changed
and this used to be chapter six of the live process bio
which has now been deleted,
similarly now let's look at this also, in this also
you will see that it is rationalized 2023
204, now in this  Let us also tell you some interesting things.
Okay,
open the SIM card,
now look here, this is your chapter, Hari
Tree and Evolution, its name used to be on the
syllabus page, only Heredity and
Evolution was written there, but
now batting bats are excluded.  What did they do?
Simple brother, don't keep confusion. Rate race. Be
no confusion. That's why this less has been done. So you
will see rationalization here wherever the date is. This is basically modified. If
I give you another example like this, isn't it
what it is?  This is our own chapter, the
rate for environment, now if you look in it, it
is again visible as
rationalized rate, so
whatever the date is of fresh coffee, if
rationalized is not written, it means that
they have lifted their own chapter, like
this.  Okay, so come sir, you want to
focus on
something of physics, if something new has been
deleted, then I have just seen it
from a difficult topic, like a thick
electric motor, then ACD generator, then
electromagnet, they could not understand it, that is,
I tried very hard.  If I used to do this, then
teach the concept of D two-three times, only then it is understood,
children, now if the child cries, if a
question comes from it in the exam, then
that has been removed, it has been made
very easy. Look, now everything else
is just a little detail.  Otherwise, the only thing is
that the syllabus has been kept the same as my dear friend,
they have not added any such strange thing. Okay, today
nothing has been added yet and if
you are getting very confused then hey.  Friend,
this is the syllabus, this is the syllabus, you have definitely come, hope
your consumption must have been cleared and also do
not take any tension that friend has been added,
something has been done i.e. extra,
do not pay any attention to that, okay,
from where did we tell you exactly? CPSC
website.  There is nothing different,
sir, you guys, the
reference book of class ninth is also NCERT, it also
gives you the test in the exam, it is
okay, if you do this also,
do the exam questions, it is enough,
okay, but CBSE.  Exam
atlist of Hey if you ask that foundation and those
who give so devar are additive things start they would teach
in our classes which we often do
ok then separate reference for that
but CPSC if we have to target then
ask heartily de mother right  Son, it's okay now, miss it and watch it like a
YouTube
discussion about the maths syllabus, tell me
a surprise, tell me, yes, I
do less, let me tell you, let's go,
that last one is amazing, I am okay, so we have to
do the series from 10th, our current right.  So
they are going to launch the classes of
Bryonier classes, right and the first two
badges will be your first and pioneer's okay, the
first will be your ninth batch, so all the
children of ninth class who were with us again and again,
although right now you are in 10th.  If you would have gone then
we thought that let's
start on the ninth as well and these classes
will be such that you will get six days and in a very
fun way we will study 90 quizzes,
quiz activities, what will not be given to you,
you will know in details, we will tell you
properly.  First of all, we have just told you the date, do
n't forget to subscribe and press the bell icon
because this
will let you know in the big notifications. Yes, of course, this is
a new beginning, we will study well,
dedicated with everything, examples, there will be
a lot of things to read.  All those things will be
told to you in detail,
they are so grateful, because of this today they
think you come back, you gas, so do
n't reduce their love, okay, the more you
keep giving, the more classes you will get.
Thoughts and simple formula
is the love of the children and the
energy of the teacher and we also get the time to come here, we also
get the formation of time to meet you only when you
give us love, so let's go children, if you
liked the session.  So please
share it with your friends, like it, no over you sir, let me
tell you once again from the beginning,
yes sir, rest of the things I think, I am
telling you again that I have knowledge
in both science and maths.
What did you put in CBSE Syllabus 2018 24 Google, the
first result will be of CBSE only,
you clicked on it, now
see here this Secondary Curriculum Secondary
and Sir has discussed it, now I will
look at Maths with you, so
see here this.  You must read the whole thing, there is
still a little time, at least get the
mentality that
people, read the exam paper which I have given, then you
will understand what happens
if I see it once, then I
[Music]
There is a thing in the hair,
look with me,
I can't say this,
I have written this marking exactly,
but that is what is going on, meaning, overall, what I am
seeing is the
real number
[music]
s, although that is not visible, I
understand from here.
Yes, these are all the same things, these are all the same
things, I also have the identity, it is the same
identity,
that is a lot of
packets, it
is here, sorry, I am sorry,
look at this, identity is very important, sir, it is
two-three,
but it was not there for one or two years,
give me.  Euclid's Geometry is coming in the second. Come on,
thank you. Look, he has kept it. This was not there, is
n't this? I see, there are lines and angles, there are
triangles, all these things
were there. Now we are going to see one thing, so they are
still yours.  No, these qualities are
not in a triangle,
now look, in quadrilaterals, we have all the
things
that you should know that you should open like this, do
not wander here and there, give the syllabus,
give the above syllabus, this should not happen, CBSE has given the syllabus
on its website.  It has been given to
you, you have to take it, now print it out
and keep it, I have also told you the method, you can
see this saree,
I am taking it and this saree thing is good
like frequency polygons, it came forward,
maybe it was not there last time, look good.  All the
things are here, one thing, now look, this is the
pattern of the question paper, that is fine,
one thing, I have to tell through it.
Well, it was from ninth, it will come last. Let us
also discuss about tenth, first
look at it in real number.  Look at me here
again I have to take Euclid division, nucleus
division is not an algorithm,
look Aditya, what do you mean by last year, do
you understand the point, what is the matter that
now it is possible, I too can do exactly all the
things, right?  Mother
had a topic, that is not that thing, I
showed you where to get this syllabus,
print it out and keep it with you, it is
so important, this is the most
important thing, print it out and
keep it, it means like it is a book,
sir.  She always used to keep the print out of her syllabus in
front of her in three folds.
Look at the system. Class 10 is the same.
Look at 10th here. You went here and
clicked here. If you will get automatic math and science,
then look at this. Real numbers are polynomial
pairs of linear equations.  It's all the same thing,
see, the thing is why are you mixing it with the last time,
last time you were
in a little trouble, this time you were in 10th, maybe the
books were for the last time, yes, it is exactly the
same thing, yes, I am telling you the right thing.
So print it out and keep it
from there, print it out and keep it
because you will see it again and again on the phone or
on some website, if you are using a mobile phone and you are
seeing it from there, then do
not do this whole thing and mark it.  You can also do it, all the
things are the same and I am telling the same thing after seeing it
because now there is
no point in telling each and every thing separately, I am saying that
this is this, this is not this, this is this, this is
not this.  Because you will not read it in a day, you will
read it slowly, so
print it out, it is
a big change, something like this, but
print it out, I am saying this again and again seriously, I am
not joking, you must be
singing.  Friend, this has come on YouTube, it is
not like that, take a printout seriously,
of course I am telling you this here also,
we
are the children of regulars, we can tell them the same thing,
see this thing which I was going to tell in the last.  So the type of questions is that
it should be right, it should be right, it is right,
whatever you see, now you listen, let's go to the paper
design here, okay see, now the question comes for the
children, brother, NCERT exemplar,
CBSE has written it,
right?  It is written in the prescribed books, it was
written last time also, it is written here, you are
seeing the exemplar problems, it is
written, NCERT and NCERT,
so it is
exactly NCERT Exemplar, which is absolutely
related to this, now see, no one can say 100%.
In Science and Maths, I am not even understanding you,
change the logic a little, it
is Bible, NCERT and NCERT Exemplar,
you have to do it, you have
nothing to do in it, you have to say that I do
n't have to do it, this is the most basic NCERT
Exemplar, apart from that  What do I have to do
in Maths and Science? We kept
telling you that and from time to time we will keep getting it done in our sessions
and will
give recommendations for each chapter. So see, this
was your syllabus. If you don't have the NCERT book,
then see.  That too you don't have to do anything,
you have to go to Google for a second, I am
showing you
like this, see NCERT PF, do it like this, if
you don't have it, see the first result,
this is of NCERT only, right, now see it from here for
free as madam told.
Everything is available for free, Class 10, now that is a different thing,
I would say that you should have a book,
even if it is
available for free, but madam, a man should
have a book. You can read it in Hindi or
in Persian also.  Yes, sorry, there
is no parcel, so look here, look in this,
now see the chapter bicep, look at the syllabus, so I have already seen it,
now look here,
see that the book is rationalized, as in science
also, Sir and I had shown you the
book here.  It is absolutely necessary to rationalize, I am
also here, see it is written here, now
look at the meaning of rationalize, many times they
required him to deliver the contact, but in the
story, I may have changed something in some passages, if I
go down in the revised syllabus, I will get a  Look at the thing exactly,
we are also watching it for the first time, I hope you understand this
because it
came only yesterday, I
mean to rationalize, they have made it as per
CBSE, very
good, what could be better than this for you,
they have changed CBSE.
Which is not in the Euclid Division
Algorithm in Nucleus Revision Syllabus,
but it was there last time and
in NCERT. Children were troubled by this. Is it
in NCERT, is it
in CBSE or not, so they reduced the pain.
Yes, you have to follow only one right, now there is a
little more in this 20, so brother,
you can do a little and then what would you say about that, for
those children who have bought the books, will
this be there in their books also, they will have to
mark it.  Otherwise,
first of all, look, I have said this 10 times,
I am also feeling that I am getting irritated, you are
saying the same thing again and again,
print out the syllabus and keep it, printout is nothing to understand,
if you print it out, Vaibhav is asking
that  Sir, channel pe channel pe meaning yeh mast bhi
meaning ki net pe kya example
dekho science as though that was a
surprise, I have already opened
that we are
starting the first series in Great 9
and pioneer for Great 10.  If we are doing a series on
D Infinity Line Class 9 and 10 YouTube
channel, then it will not only be of CBSE,
we will obviously
add some flavor of foundation in it, we will ask
exemplar questions of date, a
little bit and some questions of NTS and
that too.  We will get a little bit done,
you mean believe it, it
is up to us isn't it and look at the book, I am telling you again,
what is required in the book, they have done
everything in the book as per you,
they have removed the things which are not in the syllabus,
then  Also, if there is something then you ca
n't fight brother Sidhi, I
just thought it was too much, let's conclude,
okay,
I am not even into maths, you see I am new, so
where am I from, it could be less, it could be
more.  It's not going to happen so here I am, I have
seen it for a second, I have seen some chapter like,
if it comes to my mind, I
think the last chapter 13 chapter,
seniors used to have 16 chapters or 15
chapters, something called
step division method.  What is the meaning of whether they have
removed it or
not, but it is not in the syllabus,
according to me, most
probability, look for a second,
just give a few seconds, here they have written Statistics
Mini Million Mode Group Data,
Mean Median and Mode of
Step Division Method.  It was not there for the last two-three
years, now it is your syllabus
because here they have just written that if you want to find out the
mean median
method, then the meaning of the food, they have
completely synced the NCERT and
CBSE syllabus, so it is only till here.
What would you like to say, so children ask.  Thank
you Vaibhav, thank you so match rate, so have
all the syllabus been updated, son, all the
books from 6th grade to 10th grade have been revised, okay and
I had already told you where
you will get it.  Is it okay from first class,
first tell me
CBSE Syllabus 202324 I have come, this
is important sir
24 Link of CBSE only click here, there is
secondary curriculum, look here, if you
want to do language then that too, if
you have any language like Hindi, English, Telugu,
date you.  Can also get and here are the
subjects - Maths, Science, Social Science,
click on this, got the syllabus and
we have just discussed about Maths, now the second
thing is NCERT Books, if you do
not have updated books, still you want to see then
wait in Google.  Just tag this in 1 second,
sir, okay, I am showing it here.
Type NCERTPF and enter it, look in Google, the
first result that will come is Date Bill B on
D website of NCERT, click here.
Pay free, I am just
giving you the cover of Class Ninth.
Yes Raid, so now let's open our chapter and
see. Okay, let's
see the structure here too. See, it
is coming after writing rationalization. Son, okay, it is coming after writing rationalization.  It
means that it is updated. Okay, so
what do we have to check? We just have to
check whether it is coming after writing rationalize
or not. We have to check that 23rd and 24th
will be our issue, so it is okay for us to keep this in mind
because right now.  Your exam is going to be held
in 24th. Mostly it will be written till March, so the
first step is to prepare for it. This is
how to prepare for any exam.
NCERT Bible. Do you understand that it is
NCERT and NCERT?  You have to
do the exemplar, they have written it below in the syllabus,
I have just shown you that you have to do the
most basic, apart from that, what all have to be done,
we are the first and in the pioneer series, we are going to
get 10 claps, we will
meet daily and study.  will talk will
do everything
Hey So Other More Doubts You Can Just Put It
In The Chat Box And They Would Be Most
Happy You Answer Dame It's So They Have Some
Student Over Her Other Fresh Doubt Vaibhav Is
Saying Responded Did You Ask
Other Doubts  Web had asked some doubt child further
on YouTube ok so we are talking on YouTube we
are so big we are standing right then
come on
and there is a price na palak I will call you also sir we
will reveal a surprise sir right
we have a surprise  It is done ok and there is a
surprise on your rate so pick announcement.
Whatever study we do is done out of
boredom and now
this time we thought that they are starting very
early and because of your love.  Of course
late we have just started quite early
so they have plenty of time you
explain things in a very different dimension very different way
so date different way
mother explain them to you know okay so
I think na some children this  I am going to
buy an old book, what to do? Hey,
no problem, if you buy an old book, then do
not commit any sin, okay, there is
something extra there, not less, so
you just have to do what someone did for
you.  There were books of scenery, that too
were of old type, so you just got your
syllabus here, that's why we came today, right sir, that's why
you came here, here you
will see your syllabus and
everything was explained correctly in your books.  Don't worry, you did
n't understand. Watch the video again.
Tell your friends also, brother,
how to see the syllabus, how to
access NCIRT, just once
in the exemplar, let me show you
what you know, I am the
seeds of the exam.  Have to open it because many of the
websites available may
not be updated, may be old, may have some editing in them,
this is yours, it
is absolutely fine, Vaibhav on D Infinity Learn
Class 9 and 10 YouTube channel where you
are currently standing on this channel.  There will be
live sessions from 10th of April for the
first series on the Great Nine and on the Great 10
Pioneer Series, watch it, you will have great fun and
study. Okay, so this is done,
see the saree example of the saree, this is on here,
friend, where else is the story of Jaan definitely not there?  So, let's start
with this, Let's be a secret
today, there is no right,
which we can relate to our lives very easily, if we
show the meaning then it seems like
bats become bats, mother is the only thing
we are talking about in this entire season.  There are going to be challenge throwers
and not just us, if anyone comes and
can challenge anyone at random, then
this saree will be our activities,
applied science thing that we do or as
you understand the concept, this saree will be
activity based and explosive.  There is going to be a series
and not only this, all this is going to give you a lot of
ideas as to how you will be able to
involve science in your weekend parties. Of course
you are going to
get a series whose name will be.
Now you will know a little bit about it.  You will know on time
but yes that will be based on our experiment
activity so science challenge you bill get it
on every week a new science
talent which we will do and you can apply it your
home so guys on tha watch
thoughts which from one side  And whatever was told today,
carefully look at it, it is very
important information, please do not get confused, do not be
afraid, we will study together comfortably, so let's
meet again, thank you so
match bye bye.